[Music]
humankind now faces a new contest of
historic proportions
but are we running toward this challenge
with the purpose and resolve required
now I'm not talking about climate change
here which is of course a significant
threat to our planet in fact I drew this
cartoon back in April of 2020 for The
Economist saying just that
[Applause]
to portray this new challenge I've opted
once again to employ a sporting metaphor
this time my early sketches suggest that
a two panel format would be more
appropriate as it allows a setup and a
punch line to enjoy their own separate
spaces
we open in the first panel with a slew
of Runners of all sorts and shapes and
sizes moving at PACE
they move from our right to our left
with determined energy but where are
they running to or maybe more
importantly who are they running from
and our second panel are old Nemesis
climate change arrives this time without
boxing gloves he choose shows dog a
determination but he is also not alone
just behind them is the robotic Specter
of artificial intelligence its sudden
appearance Into The Fray Grace's
questions has it come to help or will it
overtake and surpass its human creators
as Ai and climate change Edge closer
maybe humankind will rally and Triumph
after all let's face it this is One race
we cannot afford to lose
[Music]
thank you